as a matter of fact you can only eat
like smoothies another thing that's
happening which is a new thing is that
of course a week ago kalila goes hey can
we foster a puppy oh yeah you know cuz I
don't know if you know this but closeted
animal hoarder now let me just say
something this is a special situation
okay okay let's hear this out let me
hear how special this is there are a few
things I'm good at
and one of which is bottle feeding
orphaned animals yeah no I know how to
wake up every two hours I'm very
disciplined about that when they cry I'm
there I also spend a lot of time at home
this puppy had been orphaned nobody was
going to take time out of their day
because they have to go into work I'm
here all week you know you know so I
thought okay let me just commit two
weeks in my life to bottle feeding an
animal then I returned it to the rescue
well I'm gonna tell you right now I was
like I'm like you're not gonna be able
to give it up she's like I can I can I'm
gonna I don't know if I can give it up
if you saw I mean it's like storybook
like the opposite of Remi like Remi is
an old pirate angry piece of [ __ ] right
and I love ya breath this little guy is
it's like a showcase animal it's true
right it's like something that you
present at a show yeah like look at this
breed high quality yeah it's the cutest
little thing I've ever seen in my
[ __ ] like cuter than Bojo I think
mojo was really cute yeah but but if you
guys are interested he's only three
weeks old now but he'll be available for
adoption through May Day rescue so you
can go to their website and fill out an
application and do all that or if you
want to be a foster it's a great
organization to work with it's ma e da Y
so what let me ask you this let's just
let me just so now what happens we i
bottled for a couple more weeks we
bottle tea and then when i wean him off
of the bottle yeah then I'm able
- hand him back - I want to ask you this
yeah
who calls who this was already
pre-planned I understand that but I'm
just saying in two weeks will they call
you alright you ready
Oh or is this something that you call go
I think we're ready I think he's I'm in
contact with them every day because I'm
obligated to send videos and photographs
of his progress yeah so this is a very
control could you do this would they
allow this just hear me out
hey yeah look at the photos and the
videos he looks great right yeah great
progress could you go I'm keeping them
yeah I can't I could I could adopt him
officially but I'm not going to do that
because I want to foster more animals
and we're animal doubt what if Bobby
says I want to keep it if Bobby wants to
keep him yeah we would have to
definitely I know but would you would
you talk me out of it yes
oh okay well then keep that little
[ __ ] away from me oh because you're in
love yes I did what he does is um he'll
he climbs on your face and he licks your
face and he makes these really cute
noises like that and he looks at you
like here's the thing when an animal
looks at you like you're their parent or
you know provider and they trust you and
that they give you that what are you
gonna do you can't go by so for me what
I gotta do now is just no more don't
touch the [ __ ] thing again help it
though because he has so [ __ ]
cuteness things like I want to eat it
that's how that's how cute is like just
to put a spear like a little stick in
the pot a cute little spear that's it a
cute one figurative yeah we'll figure it
I'm kidding I'm not gonna eat it guys
may they rest 100% the best best
organization in town get me in trouble
I'm kidding I'm not gonna know I just
they know I'm a comedian alright and
we're not gonna eat the [ __ ] thing
they call tomorrow yeah Asian
boyfriend's gonna eat the dog
no it's it's just cute so if you guys
are interested in I don't know man I
don't know you guys will probably keep
it I've actually don't really believe
that I really do I saw I know how you
guys are
I owe you piece my Liam you're saying no
your because just historically I've
never had problems giving away puppies
well let's give away Remy
no Remy I can't give away because he's a
senior and he's he's you know he's
broken he has a broken spine that those
are the dogs that are that are not going
to be easily adoptable to a lot of
people those are the ones I want to keep
but the puppies there so II everyone
wants a puppy and those I have no
problem giving away and plus by the time
they start to teeth and I I'm not in a
phase in my life where I want to deal
with eight months of teething well we'll
give you an update because I don't
believe a word she [ __ ] I wouldn't Bobby
I don't just you wait I've given a
puppies before I bought a fed puppies
before
[Music]